[Music]
oh
[Music]
hey so sorry i'm late i i just no
worries i'm sure there was a lot of
traffic from your bedroom to your living
room
you know how it is monday mornings today
is wednesday
anyways um any updates on our customer
blinder.io
yep i finalized the design and the
proposal
and later today i have a design review
with the broader team
and then after that i have a sync with
the customer where i'll propose the
infrastructure solution
good uh let me know if you need any
support for me but
that's all i have for you today oh yes
um
performance review is coming up you said
that if i let this project
i hope you set up for a promotion
one performance sorry go ahead
so as i was wondering oh sorry please go
oh okay cool um uh i'll go down no no
that's not what i meant
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks everyone for joining i'll be
talking about the infrastructure
proposal for the company blinder
uh they make um hey steve
do you uh do you need some time to nope
i'm good
okay um so as i was saying
uh blinder provides window blinds as a
service
and i'm sorry i just want to say that
it's totally okay if you need to sit
this one out and deal with why would i
there's nothing else i would rather do
than listen to your well-prepared
presentation
[Music]
on second thought you might be right
sorry honey i'm coming
as i was saying a company offering
blinds as a service will definitely
require
shoot am i late i'm so sorry i i thought
it was scheduled at 2 35
not 2 30 on the dot anyways
so here is my proposal for the info
changes to allow for horizontal scaling
uh any questions
all right well if there's no questions
uh you guys can get 25 minutes back
thanks bye
[Music]
[Music]
of course
[Music]
yeah so that's the high level overview
of the new design
for blinder uh do you have any questions
sorry it's um it's not a big deal but it
kind of bothers me
so the company name is blinder
without the e so it's blinder
um okay yeah blinder
no blinder blinder
all right we we can take this offline
for another time uh what were you saying
yeah do you have any questions about the
design oh yeah
here's the thing i don't see machine
learning
anywhere in your proposal uh you sell
blinds to customers no no
we sell privacy we sell security we sell
the peace of mind and window blinds are
merely the means
for that with with machine learning of
course
oh okay um what what data sets are we
working with
uh are you collecting their feedbacks
and their returns wait or
wait did did you not hear a word i said
we are all about privacy so we would
never collect data from our customers
actually i i think i understand
our intellectual discrepancy okay oral
communication
it's lower bandwidth medium i get it
it's not your fault
let me just show you a powerpoint of our
design i think
it'll make a lot more sense once you see
the diagram
all right do you see my screen um
i see your screen but i don't think
you're sharing the right one oh there we
go
so you understand now right the
innovation
just a second
sorry i had a delivery come in um yeah
we'll we'll look into that um do you
have a team of machine learning
engineers
uh to work with us no why would we
well how are you gonna maintain all this
new technology in your system
well that's for you guys to figure out
isn't that the whole point of your team
anyways i gotta go my masseuse is here
oh one more thing
block changed we'll talk about that next
time
i'm sorry
this morning was a very good time
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yes sorry about the angle um i don't
have a tripod but
thanks for watching i have two
announcements the first one
is that i'm starting a new channel
called joma
in nyc so it's basically a vlog channel
unfortunately it's not about tech it's
more of a lifestyle vlog
so if you're still interested in that uh
check it out german nyc
and then the second announcement is that
i'm starting a newsletter
so i know i don't post a lot on on
youtube but i still do
want to share stuff with you guys so the
newsletter will allow me to do that i'll
talk about i don't know my investing
strategies
life advice um recommendations for tv or
youtube videos
so if you're interested in that uh check
it out jomopa.substance.com
it's free everything is free so um yeah
i'll see you there see ya